thank you
foreign
not only our partners
and communities too and that was really
helpful I think for us to to to not only
um try and get a consensus to share a
consensus and understanding of what the
family book or doctor but also really
look at what our local assets already
are and how we can build upon those and
I think the important bit with the
family Hub it doesn't necessarily need
to be a building either you know there's
lots of ways of delivering help for our
families so really thinking about the
digital offer and actually it could
operate out of our current asset schools
a very powerful asset libraries and
Leisure centers it could be so
multifaceted so we just had a a really
good opportunity to brush out some of
some of that detail thanks camera I
think that's probably on the the next
slide and these words were the ones that
came out when we had our Workshop of
what we wanted our ambition to to be
founded on
thank you
and that was our star transition and
that was our agreed ambition
that came out of the workshop
and then obviously we went on to the
actual key features of the family hubs
which is on the next slide and again
that was agreed as part of the workshop
for the partners and with families and
that's what everybody was telling us
they ought to be about absolutely about
being welcoming absolutely about being
inclusive and that Community Based alone
is really really important
visualize some of the the workshop
material that we worked on and we shared
thanks
[Music]
now that's that's a bit tricky to see on
the screen there what that says is you
know that we do have a really rich asset
across Trafford you know we do have some
of the statutory we commissioned as
we've said like schools and you know
like our early years provision the fact
that we've got traffic team together
already being really successful in the
local Authority some of our talk shop
the health sector all of those things
are statutory commissions and they still
have a place within in the family hubs
and then looking again at what the
voluntary sector can support with and
then what's available in individual
communities so these were some of the
rich assets that we know we've got to
utilize and harness and really bring
together to develop a family
right
and that was something that we wanted
again that just articulates our ambition
for our family helps
if you want to talk through that one
coming up
okay this is this is our anticipated
timeline of of implementation so so very
much looking at between now and
September and identifying some pilot
sites pilot areas and pilot age groups
because of course there's different age
groups and that we want to the early
years and post 18 we want to be
inclusive across the child's family of
the journalists there and and the sort
of the piloting would lead to a design
phase and will then identifying what
works and unlocking the new conditions
for scaling family hubs across Trafford
biceps
just wanted just to to draw your
attention be able to an approach that
we've brought attacked and tested and
evaluated over the past eight past 18
months which is the Trafford team
together which is a system enablement
approach to meet the needs of any child
and their family living in Trafford and
are attending a Trafford educational
setting so it's very much based around
where children are the predominant
amount of time is in schools schools
know that well no the family well that
it was building on that strength first
approach really and we've had during
evaluation and feedback from children
and families and from school partners
and other partners as well in terms of
the impact of that coordination which we
heard at the early Health Board
just to get a little visual of um of the
actual model and they're the key
Partners so there's a core team that
will be around
um the the school and then there are
Partners who we we bring in and we've
we've had um
seen real benefit really in terms of
some of our commission Services being
around the table with chapter two
together and being able to meet the
needs of Children and Families at a much
early Affairs then perhaps would have
been done previously
so it's about building upon that
approach really as as we we take forward
with with the families what's worked in
in terms of those Parliament creators
we have a number of key
um intended outcomes through trafficking
together some of that is around
resiliency families preventing crisis
improving School attendance in improving
Health outcomes particularly in
relationships and children of people's
emotional mental health
foreign
I think these are really powerful
statements
um that have come directly from parents
and schools in relation to the
difference that this approach has
enabled for them and we're really rural
outfits at the moment we put it up into
localities in Trafford and now we're
rolling that out across the borough as
an agreed approach
yeah
so by September we are hoping that
trafficking together as an approach will
be in all schools that is our aspiration
we we continue alongside that to have an
intensive Family Support offer as well
which is an approach really which is a
multi-agency whole family Approach at
that next level really for families that
need more than what property together
coordination approach is able to deliver
so it's very much a case management
approach a key worker working with the
whole family and sometimes a very
practical help is provided such as
attendance at Key Health appointments if
that is a struggle struggling to get to
those so it's practical but it's also
relational and it's talking through some
of the the sticky issues really in
families
foreign
[Music]
distinct areas that were on the
pictorial representation so that we we
think we need that Universal office
offer through the family hopes we are
going to have it continue to have the
chapter two together approach and we
will continue to have a case management
approach in public support and they will
be managed between Karen and myself who
work closely together and will both be
um driving and leading the work moving
forward
that's really exciting opportunity I
think and certainly building on the
success and working out the interface
between these different parts of the
service but hopefully strengthening it
along the way
brilliant news thank you so much
um I'm going to ask if anyone has any
questions
um
thank you thanks for the presentation it
does look really good
um since the question that I have is
around obviously
um the family thoughts and how how they
will develop in the future and
um and I did know that
um
we don't need a building but
it it it's a anywhere within that you
can bring families together because you
learn so much you know we sort of
through each of the families so I just
wondered how how that aspect of it is
covered
through this
I think what you know what we've got
we've already got two early health clubs
as you know in the borough you know in
Partington and instructed as well so
which are fantastic
for assets so absolutely got to
capitalize on as the visual kind of
showed really what we're going to get
um actually in the borough and then
again what it might look like going
forward I keep you know we we're
actually appointing somebody that's
going to head this up so we are
appointing ahead of early years in
common who will have that responsibility
for driving forward with the company
ambition I keep saying to Jill I've got
to manage expectations here we will have
to pay some stage in it because it's a
huge piece of work it's incredibly
ambitious and we know we're going to
have to you know pull together the staff
and look at the team around and the
implementation and the development of
the family hubs but I think we start
with you know we've got the two helps I
think the digital offer is going to be
really really important this is about
working with communities to say where is
it that you want to meet because they'll
they'll tell us where is the best place
in their local areas to actually come
together and meet from what core
services are you looking for and what
support I will just say one thing that
you know we're really clear about the
family hubs as well we have to get a
really strong start for life and you
know I think again we're really
passionate about that that not to that
start for life offer has got to be
really really strong within our hubs too
and that's something that we're going to
be committed to even though we know it's
you know it's not 25
okay okay can I just add the
difficulties that
um I've been having I remember the days
of the family center and how many we had
and how successful they would they were
um I mean it sounds very much like that
in one sense but it's more Collegiate I
think and put things in lots of other
services in into that but
um yeah it's really interesting and I
think the way that it gets developed you
know will be
good to follow
I think I think you're absolutely right
that obviously in terms of family
centers in terms of children centers in
terms of the short style Journey it's
important that we think about what was
really successful but we also need to
think about what was the most successful
so some of the drivers about this word
children centers needed to be where our
show starts dentists needed to be
nationally not just in Trafford when
necessarily learned by those places that
families naturally went to where they
felt comfortable there was a
prescription to what needed to be
delivered and offered through that in
some ways the beauty of the fact that we
didn't get there it was December the
19th Karen how you can forget that date
just before Christmas that we had to
submit last year the fact that we didn't
get it means that we can genuinely
develop and design our own family homes
what that looks like within the whole
context of help offer I hope what you
got from the presentation was was that
real flavor that it's not one thing
called the other it's the collection of
all of those Services coming together
the points about the buildings and
saying a family Cook is not necessarily
the building it's the service delivery
at those accessible points and places
that that families and children and
young people choose to go
can we be one of those pilot sites we've
got the building what can we co-create
what can we develop together and you
think we'd almost plan this because
um Laura was instrumental in some of the
things that helped shape our thinking
from that commission service provision
so the richness of what we've got with
our third sector providers and actually
how we build on the services that they
offer with the fact that quite often
they are the providers of services that
families feel comfortable going to so
the the challenge for us and white cat
and saying we need to manage
expectations is knitting all of this
together to be a single seamless Journey
for families
it's good to be challenging at times
there'll be Lonesome books along the way
we'll do some things and our families
will say that's not quite what we had in
mind there'll be some things that we
need to think about from our Collective
children's Workforce Service development
but hugely exciting and
it's Testament to the support that we
can't collectively from from the council
because actually we're not necessarily
required to deliver all of these
services that will really be clear our
satisfaction in getting in early and
getting in early
starting with our very little ones it
starts from minus nine months and
she went people have a little bit of
difficulty we all need help at some time
you know so there's two elements to the
early aspects but what we want to move
away from is the concept that only
helped to actually family health because
we do have to generally engender and
embed that whole family approach
thank you and Council Proctor thank you
hi so I bet you know what I'm going to
say because I say this a lot there's
nothing here about the formal evaluation
and unless we know what where we're
starting
we don't know whether we've made any
difference and I've got to take my
glasses up now so I'm sorry you are
wrong
on the timeline you've got a local
evaluation framework but not at the
beginning
and it needs to be right at the
beginning we need to evaluate our
families at the start before in these
dimensions and then evaluate them again
but the energy of the information
process because if we don't we can't
measure if we made any difference
whatsoever and then in the
um I don't have to be doing that
anyway
timeline as well that talks about
um feedback proms
but again it's got to be embedded right
at the beginning because
if we don't do a baseline assessment we
can't tell if there's been any change
and I think Joe flow which is great it
really is it's got an absolutely valid
place in any form of assessment
and we also need
solid assessment
um when in the 2000s when I was family
coordinated we used a wide range of
assessment tools before and after any
intervention and then three months and
six months posted the intervention so
that we could see the new country had
that's what I want to say because
without that hard data
as well and I'm happy to talk to anyone
about assessment tools and graduation
because so a couple of things what we
didn't convey in those slides is some of
the tools that are already being used in
Trafford team together so one of the
things that we had and we have as part
of our comfort team together model is
what we call the handbook and that
handbook not only moves the principles
But it includes a range of tools that
can be used a range of interventions and
wonderful things in our offsets and
feedback as one of the keeping in touch
meetings one of the inspectors said we
saw some stunning for a school where the
school was approached children's social
care about what interventions and what
health and family might do give them
some advice and school was actually used
directors the interns of moving some
things forward so I absolutely agree
with there's different levels of
evaluation this month is whether the
overall program whether it be overall
Service delivery is effective and one of
the things that we have just secured is
smoothly from DFE
that includes
includes Journal evaluation and
trafficking together so we're just in
the process of securing that evaluation
that evaluator and to say like you say
well we've got all this stuff or does it
make a difference and how do you know
what we didn't include in those because
again we need to think about what the
indicators what the heart measures are
as you might be saying Council of
Professor in terms of has it made a
difference some of that inevitably will
be I'll be reducing the demand but one
of Karen's points about expectations
when you start something yeah we know
that we will feed and increasing because
we will identify on that need so that
bit about it will go up before it goes
down
you would hope that one of your success
measures need to be actually people are
getting great help at the right time so
we wouldn't have some of those fixed
things
we know that one of our indicators will
be we really know when we have this
previously in terms of some of the
performance informations the number of
calls only help assessments that are
completed by partner agencies in trumpet
it's really low they're usually
completed by the local Authority well
actually if only have early health is a
shared responsibility what does that
look like so we want to co-create a
different assessment tool with our
partners to think about what the worries
have we made a difference using things
like family outcome stars to to track
trajectory so they would be
comprehensive performance Frameworks
as well as the whole emotion like that
interventionism and passing on because
it's about doing some of the work with
families to enable sustain change so I
know I'm not saying it will look exactly
like this was that you know you do need
to say oh yeah the services that we're
providing that will involve formal
evaluation results from the track the
team together because that's already
looking at the rollout and it will
include user feedback and it will
includes having clear performance
measures and kpis
system as well as some of those tools
that we use I would just advertise it if
I may cancel the party and you know we
we're linking in with the annaproid
center who you know provide an awful lot
of information clients resource and
support for family books it's a national
Center and we followed their kind of
model for the workshops and it's really
clear that that data Gathering and that
intelligence at the start of the process
is really really important so the joint
strategic needs assessment could be not
only for the borrow but for the local
areas or that population you need is
really really important that will feed
into what the offer needs to look like
as well and that I think will be helpful
in some respects to understand the needs
at the time the other thing that we do
conclude is the system guide maturity
Matrix for early help as well and that's
something that you know is is really
helpful for us whether that can be
shared too where we can see how mature
we are in terms of our model and against
our other GM and colleagues and
counterparts and the other thing a part
of is the GM coming up Network as well
so there's lots of learning that we can
get from places like
this
you can certainly harness
yeah okay
I still haven't heard anything about
Baseline assessments of Children and
Families before Oh as soon as they
engage because if we don't have that we
can't measure any change
um effectively yes we can we can do that
oh yes
um
a channel that I attend school 93 of
time now which Regency is 92 percent
that's a pain and measurable thing
but there's nothing about how does that
child feel now how does that child
relate to their family how does that
parent relate to that child now if we
haven't done the assessment right at the
beginning it's a complete waste of time
doing assessments at the end because
we've got no way of measuring change
I think we do have some baseline
information and things like you say that
if attendance is a worry that might be
an indication of other things that are
happening getting a wider plan like
going back to Karen's only a point about
early years being a passion I mean we
absolutely do know whether our children
are our school already and the measure
like nationally makes it slightly
changed but we do have a range of
measures so actually saying what are our
Baseline indicators where are we at
currently on a population level on a
ward level that had to be compared to
our statistical neighbors because
actually the point that you're making
about or is the investment making a
difference are we making a difference at
an individual level there will be a
whole basket of indicates and I do think
we have some of those so we didn't used
to have the level of developments and
School Readiness measures we do Karen
you're going to have to remind me about
the asqs yeah excuse and this is
[Music]
thinking about some of the differentials
so we know that we do have health
differentials between the orphans and
Emperor
of School Readiness
um
where we need to focus our attention
sitting some pockets of the world so we
do have that whole level data that will
provide something that makes Land
do you think
[Music]
before I ask my question I just wanted
to say that I'd noticeable Studios
mentioned tons of times in this report
bars we know I wanted to put on note my
thanks to them for the amazing work that
we're doing Trafford
um I know you said that the bid that you
applied for was unsuccessful how do we
plan on performing this going forward or
is that still in there
so what we what we're talking about here
is reshaving and transforming existing
resources so we've talked about the two
really helpful because they're so
existing imparting and Stratford the
hooks are not just the buildings we've
got staff within those and that that
delivers services we do have commissions
contracts with the sector providers we
do have resource that already sits in
intensive family support we have already
invested in um trafficking together so
this is about how we collectively use
our resources to
I don't wanted to say work in a
different way but some of that F working
in it in a different way working from a
strength Facebook perspective joining
that's all so we do actually have call
funds and that will be utilized in
respect of this we are looking to our
partners to say what's your unique
contribution to this so Health visitors
have to be a key element of this and we
do have health visitors already in
mapura there are some elements that in
terms of people like Health Grants that
would be delivered through this
arrangement of services that doesn't
mean to say that we're not going to look
for those opportunities to build more
funding and to enhance the offer because
I think one of the things that we are
saying is we all need some of our
investments resources around the system
to intervene at that earlier stage
it's definitely a challenge I think the
funding because some many of our GM
counterparts would have received from
regards philosophy just because of
deprivation factors and so on and so
forth of which Trafford unfortunately
doesn't you know if we're not eligible
for that for that support even though we
know we've got pockets of really severe
deprivation in the borough and I but
there may be an opportunity to bid not
for as much money but further down the
line anyway should they release another
round of funding and I think we're
probably in a stronger position so we've
got the infrastructure to demonstrate
that we're already kind of got the
wheels in motion
a supporting families Grant
and we we did think that grants might be
time limited it will be time limited but
it hasn't disappeared altogether and
that provides some of the indicators
that councilor Proctor was asking about
how will you know what a difference will
it make it's actually it's how we use
our Collective resources to best effects
um so we're trying to bring all of that
together clearly there's a whole
Workforce Development and the change
management piece around this but it's
instantly exciting I think
thank you thank you
um comments please
um the staff that are going to be
um based for each home is it going to be
um sorted out on on a needs basis or
yeah so it will be it could be done
program answers to the number of cases
and well will there be sort of changes
and stuff from welcome to another or
because you're just going to explain it
you know in terms of the homes the hook
sir will not be case holding
practitioners they will say send me
intensive Family Support
um aspect of the whole system really
what you point about does the size of
the resource in one area look exactly
the same as another area no some of the
theory of change work that we've done
with the Innovation unit has helped us
identify the type of roles the type of
practitioners the type of skills based
on what families and old children and
young people are telling us so there is
something about the called will not look
exactly the same it will not be exactly
the same in terms of what Building
Services are delivered from it
absolutely does need to be unique space
which is like Carol would say actually
we're in a good position about our Dream
strategic means assessments we've got
one from a year ago we're refreshing
that we know that needs have changed not
least because of the pandemic so
actually what that delivery looks like
and what we need to have with a slightly
different in different localities
supports and it's got a Resonance of the
stronger families and that that we used
to have in Trafford
is something is that the case when I
come in there it is a significant part
of the work that is is completed and
helping the families that meet the
chromatic area and for the now stronger
families foreign
and back to Council of practice Point
really
um we did do an internal evaluation of
Trafford team together as one element of
the system and actually partner agencies
were really positive and the the
for me one of the exciting things is
it's not about every practitioner doing
exactly the same because actually to
harness the strength of the partnership
you do need people that have benefit
expertise you do need people looking to
deliver because they're parenting
interventions you do need people that
can work with strategic and ages and
I'll probably include my own children in
that you know it's not one size but it's
all and that's why it says about how we
harness the strength of all of our
Collective Partners in terms of what
that looks like we have a richness of
information from the contracts that we
do Commission in terms of how many
families that we're reach in what
difference has it made building muscle
up into our needs assessment as well as
listening to our residents to our
families and it helps us shape of that
delivery needs to look like
okay
um thank you I was just wondering if you
could briefly describe the pathway that
a family would have gone down the ends
up with them being assigned an intensive
family support
that almost implies it's a linear
process and I don't think families exist
in a linear process
I don't think it's going to be linear
but it's I mean identified in school and
you know what are the different other
different agencies is potentially all
the people who visited because I think
one of the things in terms of our offer
that we're really trying to make sure is
whatever the worry is whatever the area
of Health that somebody needs that there
is it's not a single point of failure or
that there's that consistency approach
so if somebody goes into school and says
I'm really struggling because my mood's
low then actually how come the
designated and safeguarded needs how can
the placenta response that's how can the
teacher respond to that and do we have
that Clarity of where to go to get help
one of the things that's really good
about the Trafford team together model
is that
um we use preschool meal as an indicator
of how often the Trafford team together
needs to come together people bring
information people bring
um
personal level details about family that
might be struggling with the whole idea
is that it's responsive so it's not
about the need to go over to Children's
social care to get some elements the
family homes's current set needs to be a
place that people are comfortable where
they might get a bit of advice and
support what people think it they need a
little bit more than that
actually shall we go to traffic team
together shall we be part of that shall
we take our information there we've
struggled with how to represent this
model diagrammatically because it's
about interlocking bits and that's why
I'm saying it's not linear some families
that Journey might be actually help
visitors paint up that needs a really
significant and it does require a social
care service if it isn't just at this
stage you will do that or a vision is to
stop talking about thresholds and levels
of need and to just talk about that
responsive offer I know that's not very
straightforward in terms of that but the
point is that that word that need is
identifying the Risen response is the
pathway that I think follow
Ed up
how long is your policy every day is a
different but an intensive support Work
World works with a family or generally
what's the kind of turn you know
obviously they've got a certain number
of cases you've got a certain number of
support workers you have this coming on
you know into the system how long is it
one of the things that we're trying to
do is not talk about cases but talk
about children and families in terms of
it because everything is real and that's
that sounds like I'm being critical it's
really important to us to to make it
real
um
if I can just just add to the answer
that
um Jill Jill get to your previous
question sometimes the Intensive public
support service come involved become
involved at the end of the social care
intervention so if a family have been
successfully kind of exited from social
care and but there's still some ongoing
family supporters that took the to
withdraw completely might and not be
effective then they will pick up and and
we give really careful consideration
about the matching as well of it's not
just a case of who's got Spirits who's
got expertise who's got an understanding
maybe of the cultural and issues with it
within the family and so we're really
careful as well at that point of
determining who who will work with this
child and family and what to to come on
to you in question about length of time
and we we're working to an aspiration 12
week
intervention at which point we'll we'll
review and of course some families will
continue to need that support but what
we're really Keen is that that support
as you say is it is an intensive
resource and is purposeful so it's
um it's about what what's the goals and
what's the aims and what is the work
that the family support worker is doing
to enable that family to achieve those
ends so around three around three to
four months it's our aspiration and we
we have a performance framework where we
all receive that on the monthly visits
and but there is also that flexibility
around the needs of individual Children
and Families
thank you
I'm sorry thanks
um I'm trying to envisage your
Workforce and what it looks like and how
that will work so qualifications and I
know you're going to be commissioning
services from other areas but what about
the people that
we pay that we we say that this is our
team and others are coming in so how
does that look what does it look like
one of the things that we've been really
clear about is that we do need to think
about the skill mix and the skill mix
isn't just people isn't necessarily
focused on the delivery of
evidence-based parenting programs we
know that we need to have practitioners
that have expertise in
abuse and violence that we know that we
need to have expertise in terms of
people that bring Knowledge and Skills
around substance misuse that one of the
things that in terms of reshaping an
existing service is absolutely that
point what are the qualifications what
are the skills linked back to the needs
assessment so we know that from a social
care perspective and three of the
biggest drivers that drive demands are
domestic abuse substance misuse and poor
parental mental health and emotional
well-being so we need to have
practitioners that have those skills
some of those might exist within arts
and sector Partners we traditionally
we've looked at a family support worker
or a social worker well actually if you
need a different range of skills we need
a combination of skills so the
multi-disciplinary aspect is how we pull
in all of our Partners Health visitors
you know people from an education
background some of our our
domestic abuse advisors but we know that
we need to have people that can work
with the adults as well as the children
because if we're not paying attention to
the adult needs well children are
reliant on the adults and their lives to
get their needs met so I think it's a
fabulous question about what does that
skill look like is it Nursery nursing
qualification for some people yes it
will be but for others like I say and
having experience and the skills about
understanding mental health issues for
an adult will be with us of the skills
so that's one of the exciting bits about
crafting those teams the other aspect
that I think is because we're talking
about the widest Workforce in the
children and family space not just the
people that we directly employ some of
those skills and expertise already exist
and within our third sector providers
within us some of our our statutory
Partners like Health visiting school and
they're saying so it is about promising
the skill and working in that
strength-based way to make a difference
to our children and families
I just follow up on that and and this
manager that you're you're bringing in
so what will she look like
and what what we've said that the post
is actually ahead of early years in
family health so we are looking for
somebody who um is really clear about
that start for life and the importance
of the staff for Life officer who does
have a background in early years uh and
then obviously an understanding of how
family hubs are being rolled out across
across the country about the nature of
an effective family Hub will look like
so we've not tightened it we said
obviously have a degree
um you know there is quite a clear
skills ask and understanding both a kind
of the national Regional legislative
understanding so it is quite a senior
position
um but obviously it's up to them then to
determine according to the needs of the
hug and what the workforce needs to look
like and I think you raise a really good
point because Workforce developments and
that wraparound of support is going to
be critical again for the success of it
because it isn't just you know obviously
we're reliant on all of the partners you
know Jill said harness the you know the
power of the partnership but we do have
to look at you know that internal
Workforce and make sure they're equipped
with those skills too absolutely is a
good point and which is
because she'll want to talk about some
of the other skill side of things that
that
um DFE movies that are said to be
secured for some of the external
evaluation within that we also of course
in a bids for Workforce Development
because we recognize this actually it is
an approach it is a way of working and
that's not just going to happen by
osmosis so we need to invest in our
Collective Workforce
our early Health Workforce within the
local
forward commissioner committed people
who've been on this journey with
Trafford many of them for a number of
years and it's about that investment in
them as well and we've we've invested as
you know through our Improvement journey
in a Workforce Development program and
that's a minimum of three years our
really help Workforce happened included
in that talking to some of them today
that have been on the planning phase of
that and they're just really
enjoying that and being challenged and
thinking about things differently as
well so and much of that Workforce that
skill exists and it's about how we skill
that workflow talk as well as it attract
some some new
um people to that as well
foreign
at the very early years of children and
families together
um it should actually save us money in
the long term because of all this
trouble that
um you know if we don't do it uh it just
gets found out later on and you're
throwing money at it at that stage and
that's what I think it is exciting and
obviously it will be much better but
um the outcome could be much better for
the children and the family so you know
I'm really
pleased with you know what you're trying
to do and I think it's uh it is
thank you and just to come back again
one of the things and that is always a
challenge when you talk about serving
health and when you talk about
prevention and so the intervention is
how do you how do you prove
some of that well if we hadn't done this
what would the outcomes have looked like
so some of the performance things that
you were talking about Council of
Proctor it is always one of the
challenges but intuitively logically
intervening at an earlier stage being
responsive providing the help that
families see they need rather than it
being prescripted
intuitively as well as from an Evidence
base has to be the right thing to do and
so I I agree it is an ambitious program
but we already have some of these
services and one of the things that we
know that and how we coordinate how can
we have a joined up approach how we have
a genital Vision how we have a way of
working regardless of whether you know
we present your needs to your health
visitor to your class teacher to you in
terms of family support work and that
has got to be a consistency to what that
experience of that offering support
looks like in line with need
okay
I've just emailed your link to the
question is
um the Department of Health question is
brilliant
but I wanted to come in on what they've
asked I've got somewhere at home
um evidence of
the cost of intervention versus
non-intervention and from memory
if you don't intervene when a child is
very small because the society is in the
hundreds of thousands of pounds for that
one child as opposed to non-intervention
it's out of date but I'll dig it up with
myself I might be brilliant it's
obviously some of the things that Karen
mentioned earlier in terms of being
hooked into the GM work a lot of the
work that has been done from gmca has
included that cost benefit and I'll set
sunlight cost avoidance and what that
looks like to the system because some of
this we will be investing in that and we
won't necessarily see the financial
benefits it might be of the parts of the
system and see the financial benefits
without doubt there will be some parts
of the system that if we avoid children
we couldn't look that through the costs
associated with that we will see the
benefits but some of this is is very
much about to invest to say is very much
about cost intervention and obviously
the likes at the early Interventional
Foundation
modeling and we all remember the graph
of Doom don't we in terms of what that
looks like and that's why you know
um we we have that Collective commitment
as a council in terms of we have to do
things in a different way in order to
get those Collective benefits
thank you so much for the report it's
exciting it's ambitious it's limited so
congratulations and and you know
hopefully and we'll receive a success
not just planner in alcohol for the
children and young people which is what
it's all about isn't it
if we could move on to the next item on
um
looked up for children and again we have
had the clients in our plans so if we
could just
um a bit of a whistle stop and have a
few points because as you can see I'm
not shout out and you were there you
know we'd like to do plenty of time to
uh
and then
shall I start us off is that okay and
I'm not playing Perry with a lower ball
and I'll do a little bit of an
introduction I suppose this one is
there's a little bit more complexity
within it so I will give a little bit
more explanation and Analysis really
around some of the information that
we're presenting this evening
um the the ask from scrutiny
um in relation to our cared for children
or hooked up to children has been on
National egg it was specifically around
placement stability and sufficiency so
we're just going to take you through and
this efficiency due to some of the
national and Regional context around a
sufficiency challenges
um at the moment will take you through
what our position is
our specific challenges and how we're
addressing those challenges and Glenn
and Laura will will be able to give and
a lot more detail
so drunkly want to take the Laura and
you're taking the sufficiency
I thought it will be used to conclude
the fly that just reminds us about
what's
those of us who work within the world of
children's social care do you know what
sufficiency means in the context of
children social care to the general
population it doesn't mean the same
thing so this is just a reminder really
of our sufficiency Duty which is about
um archive and to ensure we've got
sufficient local accommodation and
supports throughout the needs of all of
our children and people in care and in
order to do that we produce a strategy
which we have done and we have an action
plan on that strategy and that sets out
how we want to move forward and improve
outcomes for our own people and also
ensure that we are good corporate
parents so a copy of our um a summary of
artificiency strategy is on our Council
website
wanting to have a look for it and it
includes a number of different areas
which which include gender and
culturalism
a need for us to place more young people
from Foster Care within Guevara that's
the name for us and also improving our
support for children with complex needs
in terms of the national context uh
you'll see here that last year a number
of cared poor children by local
authorities across England Rose by two
percent to 82
170 young people and that's just
continuing the rise we've seen across
recent years
local authorities are seeing an
increased complexity of leading young
people and some of this will be due to
the impact of covered and as you all
know there was an independent review
completed last year by Josh McAllister
he identified a number of key
recommendations one of which was around
the importance of family health and
links nicely to our user generator and
another recommendation was also around
the fixing the social care Market
um which just causes a number of
problems at the moment which leads on to
the next Point around some really large
organizations funded by private Equity
firms which leads you to question either
do they have new people's best outcomes
at Art and there's also a recognition as
well by central government those
supported accommodation services to our
care experiencing people require some
regulations that's a really positive
in terms of the regional context
um not not too different really in the
Northwestern that we're seeing
increasing numbers of careful children
and increasing complexity of need so
exactly the same as what we're seeing
actually really in terms of the
Northwest if we're looking at
residential beds actually our
sufficiency sufficiency is really good
we should be able to place all of our
young people within the Northwest but
we're up against other local authorities
from outside the region
so that's a real problem for
forwards we do have strong working
Partnerships across local authorities
and in the region places Northwest uh
facilitates lots of really good work
amongst the authorities and then more
locally we have GM and gmca facilitates
a lot of work and sufficiency so we work
closely with our partners across GM and
there is a GM dashboard which includes a
wealth of information on there and the
next slide we'll show you a graph which
I thought might be useful and we also
have a GM sufficiency strategy and there
are a number of things there which the
GM sufficiency strategy is focused on
so the next graph is uh just summarizes
the rates of cared for children across
Greece and Manchester over the last few
years and there's also comparison with
GM comparison to the Northwest and also
comparison with England which I thought
might be useful for you to see and in
terms of GM authorities we are 68.9
which is just slightly higher than
Stockport so we you know the picture
looks looks good compared to our
neighboring authorities compared to GM
as well it looks good it looks good
against the Northwest however the
England race is actually a little bit
lower than Trafford
so as you can see you know around 380
March 20 we're spike in December January
21 as you can see the downward Trend
which is really positive if you have to
try out the children's more children not
less children without care for them
trees as well
children in traffic some of those sorts
of testers is where we had children at
home or care orders what we call
placement parents where we share the
present responsibility through the
courts we significantly reduced the
number of both placement and so you know
those children who you know whoever
discharged to care or they're no longer
get cared for and we're sharing with
their families and we had real success
and we could continue to have more
success over the next 12 months around
where children are living predominantly
with um Foster carers and reconnected
people with friends or family of those
children who've gone on to achieve this
book professional gratitude board
doesn't have responsibility for those
children but they take them out of the
cats
cat or children something you can see
that's really positive progress in
Trafford over the life of March 2016
and we very much hope to see that
continue but we are probably you know
it's important to say we're probably at
that you know there's not a huge amount
of
um
probably think of the right word you
have not a lot of river room now to
continue to produce that we've probably
got the right job in cares for but
there's still you know
do so in terms of the types of places
are 314 cash for children majority of
brilliant police and children are living
happy homes they're living with um
connected persons Foster carers or with
um our internal Foster carers or in the
high percentage agencies
um we've got 19 children that live in
what language that still children homes
about a condition replacement through
Laura's team at
and we've got is it nine children
because in our current
um internal Children's Health so you
know I'm really pleased about our
specialty aim is for more children to
live in family settings so be very much
you still recognizes to make sure that
your children have the opportunity where
to write an appropriate sort of in any
public setting
so just again it just gives a quick
overview of the ages of children so as
you can see the majority of our children
is 10 to 15 which tends to be our most
tricky age group to find the right
appropriate get out of placement homes
for our children to live in
um we've got 81 children again in that
sort of 16 to 17 cohort that would be
very short
experience young people so making sure
we've got them right accommodation for
them and make sure we've got the right
and use of services and you know 13.5 of
our children
so again in terms of this team it won't
surprise you but you know the majority
of the makeup are careful children
stands at 67 but we are seeing a rise in
you know none of my British children
coming into cat so again that's a
challenge for us when we're thinking
about how we eventually have the local
culture and appropriate placements to
make sure that our children are careful
in line with that with their needs so
that continues to be a challenge for
both in traffic
location so you know 57 of our children
place within Trafford now you know we'd
like to see Mountain rise we'd like to
see more children place in the borough
because we know people displaced
children
so friends
of traffic that's really important to us
so again you know we need to think about
how we increase our sufficiency in our
area
we're doing that I'm pleased to say that
we expect children would be great in
Manchester so that's really positive we
know great monitor to Transportation
into the section and internal access to
Services is really really positive 96
again that's a really important thing in
the Northwest
and there'll be particular reasons for
about you know perhaps your likely to be
in line with you know what that what
their needs are currently
so long-term placement stability you
know it's calculating a number of
children under 16 and we looked after
different at least two and a half years
and I've been in their current place to
to the South Side sort of how that
calculation methodology behind that to
travel to perform really well with
regards to this and we've got to answer
we've just recently got into 75 of
children having what we call good
classes developed it so it's still
further work to do with work
and what we can do about to how we can
better support our children to ensure
that children have
um
we've had a very small number of
children before the same that they're
experiencing news
in sort of real life
so how are we going to improve placement
stability so other than just like having
children and have the basic stability we
know it's a sport we have a lot of young
people that we've got to contact with
training to make sure that they have
that stabilization it's an area of
practice that we know you've all seen
the Ambitions partnered very much within
ambition before to make sure the place
and stability is at the half a lot of
the work that we do we have a permanency
strategy and we've got to implement that
into our practice it's not just that you
know a report that system on a Shelf
everyday social
caps and stability for children young
people we're just about to move into
setting up opponent's panel first one is
tomorrow and I'll be looking again for
those children
potentially where we can look at premium
permits through discharge for care order
if that's appropriate special guidance
across the camera we want to say to
children people this is your as fast as
possible throughout the home you're
going to stay and you're going to I'm
going to look that and it's ongoing work
we continue to do a day-to-day basis
about how we have better care funding
helping measure the right plants
time to help you drive forward with
those care plans towards permanence and
we've actually said we know that
planting disability will have an impact
of where we are able to safely discharge
children from becoming Who Remain cared
for
so I thought it'd be really important
that we sort of give you a little bit of
themselves
experience of a couple of young people
so we have a young person who you know
who's 10 years of age and became cared
for lots of reasons of say gun issues as
to communities
but people who know what Rochester
brings alive but I'm super suspicious
eight different places
with the children's homes South Africa
really challenging for us to think about
for such a young person a young person
currently lives in a four bedroom
children with my neighborhood and great
apology I think it's really important to
life because a lot of complexity of
course
it's kind of lost you know public person
at 9.5 hours
per week to look after this traditional
person the reason for that is that
receiving a hang up the cap so they have
two members of Staff who can actually at
all times
complexity and vulnerability
to enable that you know person to remain
in that home safely into the house on
some of the costs we
completely appreciating on the right
hand plan for that young person looking
for fostering places like a very special
skilled foster parents who can look
after this in person I'm going to need
to go on a really you know strong
background package of support to get up
make sure we've got a placement
stability to ensure no certain places
and breakdowns how to move around in
places like short space of times a lot
and in terms of case study too you know
we've got 15 year old 50 year old young
person who's been in that placement
system I think this year in person
breakdown
about your adage reduces Electronics
for growing up like slightly the person
having to afford from 19
borative and we continue
to present with lots of challenging lots
of complexities and lots of worries for
us
most recent places
and they moved into that current and
provision again I want to bring to life
the costs around because of sufficiency
because of the remarkable place you were
trying to find the right place at the
right time for an American person who
has passed us in case classes 12 we own
12 and a half thousand pounds per week
after if you're in person again due to
public complexity would be sure the
person currently we've seen three months
of stuff
okay
so yeah
so again it's just a very quick some
more sort of demographics in terms of
where our children are again so we're
wondering for um children currently
placed in our internal fostering
services and the head of services
responsible for that
we've got about 43
um
British the average age of our children
provision is like a years of age so we
still know there's a number of years
have been looked after 54 percent of
that place
um
having the placement at least one year
very pleased I've been in those
workplaces
73 percent of no children are placed in
traveling the small portion of them
outside the local area you know unit
cost is what we call back from the turbo
wash replacement is around 400
percentage
so again when I talk about connected um
people we've got 90 connected persons
placement for our children every people
that we can have a big relating to do
and we'll have an established
relationship with
I hate to spend both children for white
British and the average age of birth to
children in those certain Provisions is
10 years of age 85 of those children
replaced by this one year after 66 or so
for children placement over two years
this is a cohort where we perhaps have
an ambition to discharge from the cats
because special guidance we've been home
not to be sure to do not need to enable
adapter
strategy will come into effect to make
make change a difference and the average
cost of that maximum is just under 400
pounds
come on so this slide summarizes the
Vision around placements with
independent clustering agencies
and you'll see that we have 50
um at the time and two of those were new
people
it's about the complex
ity and again a fairly
[Music]
you know number
of times thinking about our demographic
interested and we were obviously seeing
more young people from other ethnicities
being placed in in the Exotic
Replacements the average age of a child
and in the natural places
at least a year and 28 have been in
placement for over two and in terms of
where they Place those is where it gets
tricky when we're going to the iPhone
Market because at least our traffic
cameras are based in Trafford and we
know we're going to do phasing locally
whereas ifas do for all their carers
from across the Northwest so this is
where sometimes we're not able to place
then you'll see that it just a quarter
of our placements are in Trafford and we
do tend to place
um in in GM most of the majority are
they CGM but we do sometimes have to go
outside the Northwest and here we have
two at the moment and the costs range
from 672 up to 1 769 and generally that
high cost is for uh own personal complex
they do require the extra skill set from
the from the carer and extra support so
the average is about 90 pounds per week
that's what we're paying at the moment
some placements were off framework and
and when we say our framework we need we
use a Northwest flexible purchasing
system which um ifas apply to and
there's a certain level of assurance and
they go through a process to be on this
particular contract and that's our route
to market and sometimes those providers
are not able to support you so we have
to go what we can call off contracts and
seek support from other life is what of
course we undertake some due diligence
and they are all regulated by assets and
that's just what what that means now
[Music]
so in terms of our internal resource but
I'm sure you're all aware we have two
children's homes here in Trafford and we
kind of I hate your point writing
because we're making people
um
within our internal position five of our
young people a place in us immediately
long-term Children's Home and being
through young people have placed in our
sort of emergency sure it's certain
religion having sure you're aware about
which are redesigning themselves to know
what we're taking forward and reached
about in terms of contract with your
children
it's a capital quality numbers and
children sort of residential estate say
very stable in terms of the uh I'm
leaving to long-term placement majority
of having that a year or more
um
been about two and a half years of age
in terms of our external residential
placements at 22 people
um in external placements at the point
of the estate it was brought together
and over the last 12 months the numbers
of
um people in residential placements
hasn't fluctuated too much specific on
between 22 and 25 it's remain fairly
stable you'll see here though
interestingly there are more males than
females in external residential
placements and the average age of a
child in an external residential place
is 15 so that's significantly higher
than the average agency placement and 71
have been in their current placement for
at least a year and and 19 have been in
the placement for over too and in terms
of where they are and it's spread out
across GM which is 52 and we've got nine
further afield in the Northwest and we
do have some placed out of the Northwest
and so I met Journey sometimes there
will be a very specific reason
why that's happened and in terms of the
costs and this is where our money goes
unfortunately but
um we can have some really reasonably
priced placements of 2755 and then we
can have some really expensive places
and reflect the complexity
will require and so that's the cost
in terms of our complex needs
um cared for children cohort that looks
like 23. so out of our 340 a very small
proportionate placement our children
and you'll see now in terms of where
they're placed and it's a real mix of in
a home with a foster care or with a
connected person but also we do have
some place in the future provision
because they need that really specialist
support
[Music]
and this is really around support that's
not about care and this is not currently
regulated at the moment who are stead so
we have a real range of costs attached
to these Services as well and they can
be very low for you people who are in a
tendency with very limited support that
we need each week and managing really
well moving towards independence Is some
much higher costs depends on on the
young person so the rate looks after
young people in in placements and you
see the range of Ages across 16 and 17.
and then in terms of those who reach 18
and we had 3 400 people in New London
and that was in a range of commission
placements we do commission two support
accommodations of specifically for
trafficking people we took these
decisions to do this because the quality
of providers in this market is it's
really varied and as prevention of the
challenges slide and and we decided
everyone to take control of that really
and make sure that we're getting the
best support
so we commissioned a provider a few
years ago to run for his court which is
five individual Flats really supporting
young people to develop their
independent skills having their own
front door and it's really really
successful service and then a year or
two later we commissioned every house
which is a little bit more and more
support that need to know I have group
provision your people are sharing how
they don't have their own Point law
however they are being supported to
developing
you know and prepare themselves to move
on and attached to that is a satellite
flat team young people so that's a
really nice meaning of thing people
might be wearing house ready to move on
they're still
report and also keep the collection that
they're made with the Stafford and the
other people at Marriott house so that's
been a really successful
um service and actually that flat came
out of something which felt like a bit
of a disaster at the time when the
landlord of the property was giving
notices being really impressive
line to find an alternative but in
natural facts we came out with a new
property and a product that works really
really well so we turn it around
and
[Music]
um
our population 340 200 king of those
have a siblings alongside them and there
are 76 sibling groups in total from 340
and after 76 44 or anything
so that's about saying 50 of those
companies in terms of how that looks for
ifas 68 of our life Replacements are
siblings and there's a break down there
so you can see how they
um the makeup of those and obviously a
sipping group of six
um very hard to find one family it's
it's impossible really sadly so so those
siblings are spreading plus a number of
different fostering homes and in terms
of internal fostering and 56 sibling
groups in General Foster Replacements of
21 of those groups are placed together
and this is a higher percentage
so I think it's important I think what
we're trying to do is give you sort of
an understanding of where we are in
traffic from the national museum contact
with really understanding what our
current challenges are because there are
some real major challenges in terms of
making sure we have the right place at
the right time for our care for our
children so what we've seen is an
increases if we talk about the month of
our complexity and the use of arguing
with people and I think there's two case
studies will probably highlight that in
terms of where children people have you
know separate placement moves due to
their needs their thoughts of the cost
Associated to that ability to access
local placements we're in a very
competitive market as we said at the
start of the presentation in the
Northwest we should have enough
suspiciency
but because of the way that other
American policies will commission those
placements from outside the Northwest
choice and options to places in the
northwest
what we recognize the residential
provider able to charge higher fees and
we have some you know although we are
able to negotiate costs and we try our
best to bring the costs down that can be
something quite frustrating quite
difficult when you're working with
providers with that contractors a
reduction we had unfortunately you know
within my services in terms of foster
carriers we had to loss over the last um
two years and we need to ensure that our
you know our sufficiencies that we
recruit more Foster carers who can look
after our children we do you know have
an aging population of foster cares here
and Trafford so the lab kids
to a decision in their life about a
number of years apart and they wish to
retire and do other things
as we talk about very quality in what we
call our 16 plus Market you know in
terms of that walks of change as a
regulatory body comes in terms of making
sure
that's accommodation
we need more accommodation for our
Academy jumping and that's a slideshow
Memphis called young people 18 plus
where in terms of children services we
still paying for them to have some form
of accommodation so in terms of making
sure that we've got more housing stock
available for our academic spiritual
people so any team that can take over
their own talency
providing across as a local Authority
and also a capacity to live a place of
finding function around some of that and
monitoring the place of relationship
management
bit more about that yeah this is just to
say that the as you can imagine that the
team are hands are almost close to 30
searches at any one time and it can be
very very busy especially in those
emergencies and the team obviously focus
on positive they're in there so it's
very difficult to try and plan in
quality monitoring Replacements we
really want to try him and do more of
that that's really important thing out
there and eat providers and also build
those relationships because of the way
the market is at the moment building a
good relationship with provider will
mean that perhaps they pick up your
phone and let us know when there is a
vacancy and and will be willing to work
with China so it's really important to
develop those the relationship with
providers and that's something where you
can find a way forward
so how are we going to address some of
those challenges that we've identified
some of the first Ambitions I've got us
to return the projects that might be
returned so we've got we've got Foster
Improvement appliances in place of the
impact on that we're currently able to
we're just currently looking to recruit
a um
establishment where I can go to the
Social Work position into something a
little bit different to try and drive
forward some of that ambition about how
how we Market ourselves how we run
ourselves into Trafford how to engage
the local community to want to put the
other people to want to come forward and
faster growing Authority so I'm hoping
you know in the next 12 months you see
the impact because the city building
inquiries increase but obviously most
importantly touched by people inquiring
to come across the cares about that
conversion to becoming foster care
in April this year we will be running a
great Manchester digital marketing
campaign when you'll see lots of them
advertisements around fostering for your
local Authority so that you expect to
see an increase in demanded random
inquiry to again through importance
inquiries how do we convert them for
those people to become and Foster campus
the um sort of block pilot in the GM
um idea that we've we've gone into
partnership with three other local
authorities across the Northwest and the
idea is that we'd be able to
um secure some meds in some homes
locally which will be repents just for
the four local authorities part of this
project and and the idea is that um a
vacancy comes up and foreign
whether or not we've got a really good
match for you in person so that puts us
in a significantly better position than
if we're up against the whole world
um trying to use secure a replacement so
it's the new approach we're currently in
the procurement process at the moment so
I can't be talking more about that in
terms of the details but that's a really
exciting
um project that we were involved in and
that fits in with the secure like access
to local events
and in terms of developing relationships
I just talked about now and that's
really important function of
commissioning and we have had a link
office for a coach where a member of my
team will have a certain number of
providers to develop the relationship
with them and that's something we're
going to pick up and and work really
hard on really embedding we have
supported a new home to open up and
travel which is fabulous news based in
understand supporting uh children with
complex needs and we supported the
provider through the process that we've
been to visit and undertake support
insurance and look at our processes and
we have been able to make a placement so
that's fantastic news of traffic in
person place locally in them so we're
thrilled about that and in terms of um
Trafford house projects which you will
be familiar with we are we embarked on
that last year in partnership with
Manchester City Council and we've
currently got cohort on seven young
people on board with that project and
that's about supporting care expansion
people and we're developing our
independent skills and finding a
tendency which will be there forever if
they wanted to be so it's not about
finding it in between it's about finding
the sort of things that they can set
down
[Music]
so we're really excited about that
project as well our sufficiency strategy
requires a refresh
um and um
that and although we will have some very
similarities in the next strategy and
and we're also going to continue working
on some other Regional colleagues around
the regulations Community for supporters
accommodation services and how we're all
going to manage that thank you thank you
very much
have any questions
okay
yeah it's
um
my question really is around the case
studies and the external residential
which obviously are very expensive
accommodations
um I mean when you look at those two
case cases it is a million pounds a year
for just two people and it is an awful
lot of money
um but my question really
because I saw it on the news today about
that home that Japan you know was
abusing you know basically
um that the people who were there
um and I made about 35 abuse and
um and it had been you know awarded and
so on but what I was going to ask you
how do we monitor those children to see
whether they are actually receiving the
care that they you know need and what we
are actually paid for as as an authority
um and how come
and I you know I think we are looking
clearly to
um to develop our own sort of publicity
um
you know we've been doing that really
for for many many years and long before
YouTube where where we've looked at
those kind of issues and I think we are
making progresses expensive back
and I know it is a very difficult area
to to deal with and I think there must
be some people making millions and
millions of pounds
foreign
[Music]
and we we need to be sure that when
they're in needs are complicated and we
actually know what's going on and I
don't know how we did that but you know
my question is
that three questions in that one yes
and the Assurance aspects I'm sure Laura
will want to come in from what we do
become a commissioning aspect and then
if I pick up in terms of sort of what
we're doing on a GM basis around some of
that sufficiency
I think I think you make some really
good points there um on one of the very
first slides it was it reference a
number of companies that are like
insignificant amounts of money and we do
away at the confidence response to judge
McAllister's review then specific
recommendations around that and I think
it it's from a number of points that we
we have and that Assurance or seek to
have that Assurance the first is in
respect of when we are looking for
Replacements I think as Laura mentioned
there are there's a range of activity
that our commissioning colleagues will
undertake due diligence that involves
checking the offset and inspection
and the um the references from the local
Authority where the provision is if
that's not ours so if a lot of authority
has pleased children there we will seek
their experience and of that provision
and that sometimes results in in places
automatically not being progressed we
then Undertake and Assurance visits and
permission officers will go and visit
and look at their policies procedures
risk assessments
um Jill and I sometimes have always
answer those for a particularly with
children do we do those visits from
don't tell them they're actually coming
we we usually elect arrangements to come
and see the provision
[Music]
the offset
not the local Authority
um and they're they're able to
unannounced we we've just had one this
week on one of our provisions and so
it's not our place to regulate it's our
place to assure ourselves that our
children's needs are going to be a good
match there and that point to place in
one of the case studies you'll see Glenn
chairs a weekly meeting for um that
young person so there is that ongoing
Assurance we we will increase the number
of Social Work visits to the child where
appropriate and of course as the
independent reviewing officer role and
function there as well so it comes from
a number of points but I'd say your
point is it is a concerning particular
one we've got high numbers of children
with complex needs in external
residential because that combination of
some of those children not being able to
communicate with difficult to tell us
when things are not not as they should
be it is more difficult not impossible
but more difficult
so just specifically on the um instances
that we recorded and use this evening
and the role of the regulator and from a
national power point of view all dcs's
and all local authorities were contacted
to
um undertaking Assurance exercise in
relation to whether we had any other
people placed in similar circumstances
and how we were assured and we were
given a set of checks and balances that
that we needed to to look at we didn't
have any new people that were placed in
those specific circumstances but what we
did have was your your person that was
placed in Wales so that was outside of
the National College dual restriction
and we were so hard for you the person
that was a place residentially on the
care provider was providing education on
a different site for both social people
given the seriousness of the issues that
have been in the media today we
completed those Assurance exercises and
we did share them with our What's called
the Rizzle our regional
improvements of fun is that because we
felt so strongly about needing to
um test ourselves against our own checks
and balances we also reported that the
process that we were following to the
Trafford strategic Saint content
partnership so that they'll decide to
off the work that we did in respect of
that
[Music]
statutory regulator which is the
individual children's
you know
[Music]
and it feels really important that we do
embody that in our day-to-day practice
Yeah I mean our course then we're told
whether it's you know growing up going
on
um
about 20 times and didn't respond
um and they actually that they were
doing well it was good
so you know and I know that
um some of these places campaigned you
know what it is
prior to even considering placement
colleagues from the the placements team
the commissioning service that Laura
manages and Glenn actually went to
physically look at the provision that we
were talking about not just the social
work but they went so where's this
locality what does this look like
because different things that is is
suddenly a feature and if somebody moves
from one placement to another on the
cost goes up books in terms of
how providers perceive needs it's well
that must be a really difficult young
person to look after because they've had
10 previous placements you know it's
like the history goes before them
I think some of the systems that we have
that oversight of our external
placements and couples talked about
sometimes myself or Pamela chess some of
it's really difficult
um care planning meetings risk
management
sometimes that it feels really difficult
with this piece of what it would be
happy as that idea what does that look
like anything else that is no then we
have to work through what can we do to
make this better good enough that's not
a comfortable position to be and we take
it really seriously the information that
you count on ethnicity costs how many
age how long and we get that sufficiency
information on a weekly basis and it
comes into the entity and we
collectively scrutinize those questions
because if if you've got somebody
supported the conversation with a high
cost you have to say is this Care by
default and all of those sorts of things
so I think we have some good not just
tracking mechanisms but some mechanisms
for that to check your balance about
what that looks like yeah there does
have to be National Solutions but I
think to to some of the complex issues
that you know created an authority
well it's having been at a meeting with
the ministers
um
regulate against cost
from the the care review what's
perceived nationally as some of the
solution that is those Regional care
collaboratives and just bringing and
local authorities together a little bit
like Regional adoption agencies because
that's simple that we've done it by now
there needs to be
a clear strategy for managing the
marketplace
surprisingly I've got lots of questions
so for those of you who don't know me
I'm for my traffickers carer and
and this is where I am almost interested
because I've seen it from the side of
the first carer from the side of the
child and my first two children we are
still heavily involved in their lives
and they are now protecting dirty and
I'm also involved with broadcast carers
and I've seen
the impact of placements breaking down
both on the channel to understand
how difficult it is for both sets of
people
and I got some
um as some of this stuff that you've
presented yes that's really great I have
got anxiety about other things as well
and that's so that's what I want to
raise
um the first one is
that we've only got 57 of our children
being careful in-house
that's too low
we really needed more for us to carers
do you how do you want to do it
just intense advice by Glenn told
develops our ambition to increase our
internal sufficiency what he didn't talk
about there and again just like you we
could talk all nice on this because I
absolutely agree the aspiration has to
be firstly wherever it's safe to do so
for our children to live with their
families where it's not we would want
that to be a family experience not
residential and Glenn has been charged
and has produced a whole modernization
plan around the top string because we
know which children we do have internal
care as well we regularly we're not
Foster careers and listen to what
they've said and we've made it to work I
say green I I haven't done very much of
this
colleagues within the service um and
really understand what they were happy
about and build trust and confidence
because we is the greatest recruitment
strategy is where
Departments of what that looks like
we've needed to think about what the
support is for our care
we know as
who is that the biggest Gap that we have
is teenagers and brothers and sisters
living together we also know that we
were really caring compassionate for us
so we've seen some of the strongest
responses to the ukrainians and the
Afghanistan Refugee crisis so what is it
that makes the altruism of the borough
something that people are really willing
to actually
it's not quite worrying good with
Plastering so it's not just about having
a shiny marketing strategy it is really
about getting into skin and what makes a
difference and we do know probably from
your time
the nature of fostering has changed
because the needs of our children have
changed so what that training got what
that supports offer looks like how we
wrap around our carers how we bring
Innovation to to support both our young
people and our kids and sadly some of
the things like some of our Workforce
ability has impacted on on what that
looks like we have completely
restructured expect surface and an
organized stuff that we have so we would
increase the Staffing by setting workers
I think it's two packages
or manager Advanced practitioners
because
just like we talk about family
seasonings called Foster careers are
families and and only putting it have an
issue in the life of Crisis you know
life happens doesn't it so being
responsive being able to score being
able to look at that and if it would be
helpful as a page meeting we could bring
some of the details of what that
fostering modernization command looks
like because we could take off the rest
of the the golets really
well great thank you my next question is
about costs
and
going from figures you've given me the
average external foster care placement
costs nearly 50 000 pounds a year
our foster carers get half of that
and when I was supposed to care it's
Swiss you were just over the road and
poaching
and we're directly contacting Foster
carers to say come and work with us you
get
four weeks paid holiday you get this you
get that you get the other and we give
you all this money
we've got to look at much in their offer
to some extent
so if there's two bits on that one of
the things is I think what's wasting the
likes of the independent Foster engage
yesterday say the actual rate of
remuneration is and what our costs are
probably look slightly different because
their management costs are significantly
higher so I think it's important that
past our approaches to deepong thus some
of the things that Laura said about some
of not just the residential homes but
the fostering agencies being
um unethical providers we know that
happens so it's a GM level we are
working to look at who are the providers
that are ethical providers can we do
develop or
um
not-for-profit approach can we have a
social investment companies Community
interest companies and I actually sit on
the the GM sufficiency boards because
it's such an important issue for us like
you say Council boxer on both sides and
we have done some benchmarking in terms
of our scheme of allowance and it's
really interesting because it's
somewhere at the top of the rate depends
because the allowance is as you'll know
is complicated it's made up of different
elements care elements skills elements
and age elements and some some age
groups we do really well because we do
less well generally we're in the top
half of what that looks like and we have
responded in a small way to cost of
living crisis because that impacts on us
all and so we we have started the
benchmarking we are looking at what
matters most wonderful things that
matters most as I'm sure you will
appreciate it having supports having the
right supports and being Concepts
because
a lot of people do not go into nursery
for the financial element they do it
because they have a passion they have a
commitment and they do want to make a
difference to our children thank you
yeah I agree
um
we we did recite Foster Care by accident
and for our first two children ending
their pay for it I went to the six
months review and the reviewing office
so it's really nice that you're here
you're not involved with the children
anymore so I don't understand what yeah
we are how can everyone
and that was when I discovered we
shouldn't pay for it anyway so
my next question is I looked at all the
following us you give me you're talking
about the home of Broadway that's
recently opened for children with
complex needs that we've got a closing
too yeah
what I don't I genuinely do not
understand if we're spending on average
300 300 000 pounds per child
why aren't we doing it ourselves
property is one thing skill of the staff
is some of the thing
um and we've we've spent quite a lot of
time talking about locals don't we book
caring for children and caring for
children with complex needs whether
that's about a learning need or whether
that's about to trauma informed need you
know having the skilled Workforce to to
be able to to meet that need is is a is
a real challenge one of the really
exciting developments that we've got to
on a GM basis is
um
we've secured working with the chief
Executives and The Wider leadership and
presenting some of our Collective
sufficiency needs because we're just
about to go live with the development of
nine children's homes across greater
Manchester so thinking about what does
our Collective need look like what does
what what is it that we want
all figures in terms of children that
are in residential care have as Laura
said remains really steady our bigger
challenges the foster care sufficiency
in terms of it
um I think the area where you probably
could look at which is really pleasing
about the Broadway development system of
our children with complex needs for
human finding a forever family might be
slightly inspirational and that sounds a
Dreadful thing to say but recognizing
the demands of wombat can look like what
needing to have a break whilst caring 24
and then some of those things and we
continue to challenge ourselves about
just the case for investors say cycle I
think our sense at the moment based on
our sufficiency needs based on the work
that we're doing collectively is there
are challenges within the workforce so
we're probably better collaborating and
so we've got the paper on this guy like
developments going to
um
CLT tomorrow and we will be posting that
on our finance and change program
sorry
[Music]
what I don't understand is if
um the family who set up at home
can afford to do that and have the
skills and knowledge and understanding
to do guys
if we're offering
three hundred thousand a year that child
from a young person
that's
[Music]
it's not my strongest point
yeah yeah I saw you with your calculator
[Laughter]
um
it's an awful lot of money to spend
on on when you look at it for just four
children
we could recruit
and I guess in order to invest in it is
who do we stop looking at so here and
now because actually they would need to
be the capital investment that would
need to be a revenue investment and we
still have to meet the needs of all of
those children currently so if it's
about how we balance and they equate all
of that I'm working through which is why
all of the sufficiency challenges we've
been put in on that GM support print the
chief Executives signed up to it that
we're saying actually what is the outlay
the capital cost what are the revenue
costs actually can we all put something
into that pot so as we all get some of
the benefits and solve it because you're
absolutely right the numbers are I
always ran gone hey from a financial
point of being the case study that we
said that we put in with the most
expensive costs that's over half a
million a year in terms of that young
person
um our most expensive placement that
we've had over the last 12 months
in person programs a week
what do we get for that 17 000 pounds a
week
this happens if that was the young
person who needed to be in a welfare
secure and their their level of
um self-harming Behavior their level of
distress was so great that it's um we
couldn't safely care in the community so
some of what we got from that was
security being able to lock the doors
sort of what we've got for that was
um dedicated art therapy psychological
assessments but the biggest elements was
the ability to contain but it's not a
position that we want to be in and put
that your woman is now living elsewhere
and
by having that period of time we were
really able to get onto the skin on some
of her presenting needs were what was
really important
and it
I I agree with you it's hugely
challenging and it's
it's not comfortable
we have been really successful at
managing the numbers available back to
Children safely down and what we have to
make sure that we have the right
placement that is able to meet the needs
and you know scrutinizing cost is one
Element but understanding just like
you're saying what do we get that's how
does that mean that your person's needs
help you understand have we got the
psychological assessment have we got
therapy in place have we got they're all
some of those things that that
sufficiency conversation that we have on
a monthly basis goes into thank you my
final question
is about the digital digital campaign
to two parts to it are you going to be
using existing Foster carers as part of
that and how we're going to evaluate
success so yeah we will be using excess
imposter care so part of a great
Manchester is care ambassadors so if
only today we've got an email for they
have gmca to speak with this character
in the band to get an absolutely on
Broadway
is absolutely important we've got
together by case our foster care us as
part of this project is going to be
successful we've been talking about the
digital marketing campaign for the best
part in the two years of course
because it's not just about recruiting
there's our attention and that's why the
new host that we've created about the
criminal intention because
people Network
sports
in our Clarity you can eat to our
children so the temperatures is
important business
and making sure you know our care has
gone into a bearish partner Professional
Network and I'm sure the young beautiful
and they're very much service
and you're absolutely please stay calm
because valuable members certain foster
parents so it's about a lot of time to
continue to do a lot of work around that
you know relationship building and
communication with our carers so it's
the second question on how we go into
look at the impact of that I mean it's
really key performance indicator sort of
expect
around 24 inquiries a month which you
know for a small amount of pirates in
this could sound reasonable but I'd
expect to see that significant increase
we're already looking for someone
through the 25 to 35 35 increase in the
number of inquiries
could be campaign going live and being
successful most important way to measure
that
successful carers there's absolutely no
you know another number
[Music]
Communications and it's getting
something out there but our marketing is
working
again so everyone
[Music]
and it might take 12 months three years
to quickly
through that process we say that recruit
the journey is around six months
requiring to approval so we start like
in April you didn't
expectations
coming from that as well but you know
we've got to get a talent because I
think again thinking about that market
space so we're in a great Manchester
we're clearly be doing this you know
increasing
um
marketing activity
because they're going to want to go
directly to the competition with also
it's not going to be sort of results
getting involved we expect to see an
increase in the marketing activity of
the ideas
so people have no choice
so I hope that answers your question
on the GM picture one of the things that
I think is really helpful on our GM
sufficiency board we do have the chair
of the independent clustering
Association sat on us and we do have the
chair of the residential providers and
their commitment to
um supports and develop some of the
ethical approaches it's really quite
strong because we have to recognize that
there will always be the occasion when
we did need to use the private sector
and it's about how we get a better
somehow we get people working towards
the same aims and the same age to be
meeting the needs of our children in
terms of those so just thinking about
how we engage with the markets in a
different way has to be part of our on
sufficiency solution
thank you
um
before my friends and family
yeah a connected person yeah
yeah and there's now I know this has
been a decline in the last 12 months is
up with any particular Securities
because we are normally you can't get
you know the prompt parents and
sometimes acceptable then obviously have
to be super supportive to fulfill that
role
um I'd say that as a positive it would
be crime because as we talked about one
of the slides around the special garage
so what we've seen as a number of those
connected persons and costume placements
convert to a special guarantee broader
and so these children young people no
longer cares but as part of the
fostering redesigned part of it and we
enhanced the support to our special
Guardians through the use of our special
geographership
we're trying to create more confidence
with our connected carers to constantly
discharge that cattle and not have any
supervised social worker no longer have
that status of the foster care but to
enable them to go and Empower those
children throughout their disabilities
on the course as you've said and and
know that there's still support us on
step back into that support if it
requires I wouldn't see the capacity
decline in a negative way I'd see that
as if we are secure model permanent to
our children young people where possibly
safe
though and just to just to assure you
that the point that we are we are
considering any new children coming into
care we will hold family group
conferences we'll look at assessments
and extended family so it's not that
we're not we're not using them and we
absolutely are we're doing those
regulation 24 assessments but I think
within the care proceedings what we've
got better at is exiting the care
proceedings with the special
guardianship order rather than a full
care order which is again is is better
performance for children I think the
other thing that we're doing is that
um actually how you help families to
have conversations as part of our
sellers in terms of family group
conferencing to see well I'm a granny
and of course I want to help out my
daughter my son if they're having
difficulty I don't need you to make me a
force to go in terms of what that looks
like but that'll just link into what
support we give it thanks into some of
the earlier conversation about the
family books you know what can I access
locally because I think running probably
wasn't expecting to look after a three
month old so what are you how are you
going to help me in other ways so this
is what we what we've got is a clear
strategic approach that thinks about at
the beginning during and actually how we
can get those permanence Arrangements in
place
just last question
um obviously people that apply to the
canvas you know there's you know
everything's thoroughly checks and it
can take quite a number of moments and
and you know they're also training has
to be given and what sorts of percentage
of
prospective careers don't sort of
you know or are not able to to fulfill
that role either by popping out or not
found suitable
is it alone I mean we know we get lots
lots more inquiries than we get those
inquiries converting into other sex
modes and I think should somebody make
the commitment to go through the
assessment the dropout rate is this
significantly less so it's that bit
above we've sparked your interest
and we know that it takes more than one
occasion for somebody to make an inquiry
to to usually convert so it's that very
early bit that we need to to Really
Target from inquiry to conversion to
assessments one of the things that we've
done in the redesign of the fostering
service is is have dedicated
um practitioners and managers to manage
the inquiry and the assessment process
because you point to verbs if it's going
to take me three years to get to it I'm
not going to bother you know again
needing to be responsive and he's into
progress that safely but in a timely way
it's really really important
and again in terms of suggesting that
the whole offering to bring something
back in more details specifically on the
fostering service and we do have a new
panel chair we've had
um panel development days we're looking
at how we can increase the diversity of
our panel and so that it's much more
representative of our Borough because we
know from the census information and the
information that you saw on the slides
you know the the makeup of Opera is
changing and palmarin from the
development day you know
who there is a lot going on in this
space And rightly so there's a lot going
on in this space because it's too
important not to
[Music]
think
and with regards to
um foster care is leaving
do you do exit interviews with them and
is there um
anything that specifically
causing this exit or
so all Foster carers who decide to
slowly because let's see what we found
it's a very low takeoff of the next
interview is the various reasons but we
do document within their sort of
resignation letter and right what we can
find is some of it is about we haven't
had anything specifically based
posturing service um support or anything
like that intending to buy an issues
with more in relation to changing their
family circumstances that someone that's
accountable you know significant amount
of time we've decided that actually you
know they no longer wish to have that we
found someone's even within that with
covid that people have to make different
sort of large choices in terms of
employment and and
there's nothing
that come out of it
earlier
instability in the research care
Workforce has an impact when you know
some you know children have different
model social workers and that's sort of
you know that breakdown communication
between certain plastic House of London
certainly commitment to be restraint and
we don't Foster carers who moved that
barrier
um
so
various reasons what we haven't had
which I really quiz I've loved you know
in the time I've been here
like we have no cost of care if you need
to go to another monitoring Agency for
example because we have lost Hospital
errors to another yeah
incentives
it's never been a lack of support being
released it's not it's not come out in
there as a national items like it's a
problem
with work and obviously it office
basis
of local invitations
because of a limited support but
actually I want to hear about that now
address those issues immediately and
make sure that and
foreign
[Music]
resignations and we have five
assessments on the way in the morning
for four three of those being concluded
by the end of March
to come back on the issue of support we
know that we need to adapt after course
and have a menu of support because as
we've accomplished the nature of
fostering has changed and so you know
and and looking after a baby looks very
different from walking after a teenager
who might be at risk of exploitation for
example so enhancing our offered support
and and having that mix menu feels
really important to us in terms of that
and again thinking about the
responsibility
within the Kindle model and our family
Focus work what we are doing is looking
at how to make sure that that offer
applies to Foster carers as well as you
know families where children are still
living with their birth families and
because having somebody just need them
to be on the edge of the flow to be able
to respond and some of that Outreach
approach is really important
residential Children's Home and ask if
they were able to understand
you've got experience yeah particularly
what challenging teenage young people to
actually go into place an Outreach to
ensure that placement to give those nice
account opportunities three or four
hours on a Saturday or Sunday at that
rate would be recognizing you know
and I guess the good thing
um just
um in the process of finalizing the
specification for our dedicated care for
children comes to and so as well as call
comes we invest in a dedicated camel
service for our careful children and
we know that our foster care is really
value that not just in terms of direct
interventions but the real people or the
children that they're caring for was
actually for them as a person as a carer
and
um
this helps like Gap because the cycle
just left we have been absolutely
disappears
um we are sharing a council Proctor and
we do have a performance framework
around what they're delivering and
that's been one of the sticky points
around finalizing the specification
um because what we've got historically
was around your reports and Saturday we
need to understand what is you're doing
and what that looks like and that's just
something that's really valued and by
our carers and again the case study the
most expensive one that we posted up
there and sense that your person has had
the consistency in support from our
whole care for children Council team and
the psychiatrist wedding wasn't into a
full profession that's really helping
provide a level of stability
thank you thank you so much to all the
people attending with up to and every
large
um
fortunately we've agreed in our fans
that we would differ and I have to be
announced that that was the impact of
the cost of living crisis on
um children and families are having been
asked if we could including that report
uh I know Karen's on now but the impacts
for our schools who are facing high
energy costs at the moment and so if
that could be included in the year
impact status as well I think it'd be
really helpful
so it might be
what we do it yeah
um
within February 14th we seem to have a
huge back from September and then we've
got three one after the other really and
we've got music Provisions within
schools we've got the outcome of the
offset inspection so I know Jill will be
with us once again
and we've also
um
I think Pamela's going to do as a report
to analyze the um
the impact
um
what it will be a combination between
myself and Karen because obviously
there's an event across okay
um
[Music]
um and I'm just in the process of
learning how with Michelle McLaughlin
NBA now and
there was a possibility that we may
um half were later in the Academy of the
Galax University
finish group reports from
two or three years ago now
um
children's placements savings proposals
I dropped
listed in that report detailing the
savings to be achieved in the
2014 till I think that was absolutely
the impact of the budget
I can't remember right
now
and Glenn touched on in terms of that we
are getting to that critical points of
how how much more can we take how does
the external budget so whether we bring
something on off those places how many
you can visit and what does that mean
for further reductions to that budget
suggestion if that would be useful
so that that one has come from like it
didn't come from the this committee it
came from the budget student process
that's why I might have taken years of a
bit of surprise but it was around the uh
one million pound of saving that's to be
delivered in the next year
I think what I've just said yeah
absolutely miss that because we have the
demographic money that goes in and comes
out and actually your head on the slides
or got young people been in their
placements for two years so we're not
going to end that placement to move it
unless it's in line with learning so it
just impacts in terms of that
because
um
uh yeah uh Juiced it before this meeting
and they said that they'll be the
opposite what the report together said
they'll provide more data by the end of
this week
questions
and it was a more up-to-date plan
figures from the YouTube uas Coast and
the evaluation I asked last time about
that
um
and obviously the time that went to
February
the evaluation that was done internally
as I mentioned earlier we are in the
process of commissioning an external
evaluation
um in terms of
um how it just feels like that we have
that independent Market rather than
walking our own homework we can
certainly get some current performance
and outcomes measures for you it is
really no matter how many of you can
help yeah thank you
thank you very much and with that I was
closest meeting I had a problem which is
the same journey home
foreign